[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings by now
you've likely seen the video tampa bay
bucks wide receiver antonio brown
stripping off his jersey in the middle
of a game after a confrontation with his
coach walking off the field and walking
out on his teammates brown says he was
cut for refusing to play on an injured
ankle coach brucerians tells a different
story so we reached out to antonio to
get his side in his first broadcast tv
interview i spoke with him not just as a
journalist but as a former player
someone who could have been his teammate
on the sidelines watching him walk away
into that tunnel
antonio brown
how you doing that was good
i don't mean how you doing in the casual
sense
genuinely like
how are you doing
i mean i try to keep myself good but you
know it's a fight you know life is a
fight everything you go through is a
fight
on the football field antonio brown is a
fighter
and considered one of the greatest wide
receivers of his generation
off the field he should be ashamed of
himself he's a team destroyer he's the
kind of player i would never
ever want to play for he's a lightning
rod for controversy after his nine
season run with the pittsburgh steelers
came to an abrupt end in late 2018 brown
carouseled around the league in addition
to rocky relationships with nfl owners
and coaches brown also faced legal
trouble accused of sexual assault by a
former trainer brown denies that claim
he settled with his accuser out of court
in 2020 he pleaded no contest to felony
charges of burglary and battery after an
incident involving a moving truck driver
and brown was also suspended by the
league late last year after allegations
surfaced that he obtained a fake covert
vaccination card
and then there was this
as you
leave the field
playing against the new york jets yeah
i want to know what happened from
halftime
all the way up until that confrontation
with bruce ahrens so leading up to that
week i'm like
i walk through wednesday and i'm like yo
i ain't got it at the trainer they're
like yo man my like yo i'm hobbling like
i really can't get it going so i let the
coach know training style everyone i
wake up uh sunday morning we have a walk
through with tom i get to the game
you know we playing the game so now it's
like the third quarter on the bench i
yo i can't i can't go i see the coach
like he looked bad like he's like he you
know he came to me so i'm thinking maybe
he's gonna come in
ask me like yo what it is he came like
could you go
i'm like no i can't go so he's like yo
get
out of here
you're done
just to be clear you would not force a
player to play you can't force a player
to play you can't force a player to play
i mean
they they have that choice it's their
body bucks coach bruce erin says the
incident on the field during the jets
game wasn't about an injury and was
unaware brown was hurt aries says brown
was angry about something else i then
went back approached him about what was
going on i ain't playing what's going on
i ain't getting the ball
that's when i said you're done get the f
out of here and there were also whispers
about incentives
and
and maybe some details within your
contract that frustrated you as well
no i don't frustrate me like last year i
knew coming into the league i was going
to have to be on a prove a deal earn
that type deal right and like if i could
play
what you think i'll be in the game
trying to make the money and you'll be
able to get those incentives exactly so
like my incentives are performance based
so i have to go out and perform to earn
it right so
i mean i got close but it's like yo what
i'ma risk my ankle how did you feel in
that moment when he said now
that moment i'm like yo
i don't even want to be a part of this
no more man i don't want to wear your
uniform in my mind for the coach that
you know i go to war red i just text
them i'm hurt that i'm trying to
still suck it up they'll go to war for
you right and like here in the midst of
the battle yeah you telling me get the
hell out of here like i'm done this mri
from october was shared with cbs news by
brown and his legal team allegedly taken
by buck's team doctors it shows loose
bone fragments and a detached ligament
in brown's ankle she said originally
they told you that the ankle injury was
so bad that it should have been
non-weight-bearing for how long six to
12 weeks six to 12 weeks so you came
back sooner than expected yes
now where do you stand currently with
the organization well the organization
got no loyalty man these guys played me
while i was hurt
knowingly
and they needed it because their guys
got hurt brown and his attorney tell cbs
news the team approached him with an
offer of around 200 thousand dollars to
check himself into a mental health
treatment regimen i have a question for
you and you can answer this
however you want to if you want to yeah
have you ever been diagnosed with a
mental health condition and do you
believe that has been a factor in any of
these public incidents i never had a
mental health diagnosis like
you know what i mean like i never had an
issue or problem i don't take pills i
just got a high iq
i'm an advocate yeah for therapy
uh
do you have a therapist in your life i
mean i try to do the nfl but i don't
really got time to consult with random
people i don't know about my mental
space or how i look at things most of
the people from different forms of the
world like i'm from the pit most of the
people we to they from the palace so how
your lenses look at life is not how moz
is i don't need to go into details but
there's public incidents
lawsuits against you yes
these teams that you joined and it
didn't work out yeah i bring all of that
up yes not to squarely place the blame
on your shoulders but to ask you yeah i
ask you
is there something you could have done
differently do you take responsibility
do you look in the mirror and say you
know what i was out of pocket in this
situation yo
i feel like man everything i did i did
because my heart believed that's what i
needed to do and in life sometimes you
gotta listen to your heart because
that's the only way i could go to sleep
at night
but i believe in my heart and my eyes
and how i look at things and things i
did i think they all promoted me to be
in this position i'm in
you have this tremendous run with the
with the steelers yeah
it doesn't end the way people expect it
yeah you go to oakland
that doesn't work out you go to new
england that doesn't work out you landed
tampa do win a ring yeah but as we see
right now that didn't work out yeah
for people that say
the common denominator is antonio yeah
what do you say to that i always do
what's best for me
i mean that's what it is
now lawyers for antonio brown tell cbs
news they have overwhelming evidence to
pursue legal action against the bucks we
reached out to the buccaneers for
comment on brown's claims and they
pointed us to a statement from earlier
this month in part saying
while antonio did receive treatment on
his ankle and was listed on the injury
report the week leading up to last
sunday's game he was cleared to play by
our medical team prior to the start of
the game and at no point during the game
did he indicate to our medical personnel
that he could not play so he seems to
tell a different story though nate it
really does and so does the mris yeah so
they him and the team agrees at one
point it was said get off the field
you're done but they they disagree about
what brought them to that moment right
right and i feel like antonio brown was
wrong and i told him that on multiple
occasions when we were sitting down i
feel like he has a problem with conflict
resolution especially in public um but
you know he does have a point to make
when it comes to being thrown out there
if you don't feel like he can play any
he dispels the fact that people say well
this is all about money i wanted my
catches he said nate well if incentives
are performing space why wouldn't i want
to go out there and perform and earn
that money yeah and to be honest with
you i was stumped and i said okay well
then what was it about he said my body
yeah he also clearly disputes anyone
that thinks he has a mental health issue
yeah he said listen
when he says no i don't have a mental
health issue i have a high iq what do
you think he meant by that in terms of
how he handled this situation
i was shocked by how orchestrated some
of these breakups that's what i call
relationships with teams some of these
breakups were he was telling me how he
was on the phone with not just the
coaches the gm's but the owners before
he was released or traded and i didn't
know that about antonio and him leaving
pittsburgh and oakland that he had
conversations with people making major
decisions so he's a lot smarter than
people think but i do feel like he needs
to take more responsibility for his
actions because a lot of this could have
been
it could have been avoided yeah well i
mean differently he seems to be sleeping
easy he says he was listening to his
heart and that's what you got to do so
all right great interview thank you